Alright,
so what does the frame look like?
Well,
I think it looks something like this,
and this is as far as I can tell,
this is the bare bones.
This is the bare bones of a variety of
things.
It's a barebone story.
It's a bare bone conceptual framework.
It's a bare bone [inaudible] scientists
to speak in Heideggerian terms.
It's like it's the bare bones world that
you live in.
You're always in one of these worlds.
There's no getting out of them.
You can move from one to another,
but you're always in a world like this
and so this is the world that you're in.
You're somewhere because you have to be
somewhere now.
You might not know where that is,
which means that somewhere that you are
is chaotic,
in which case you need to go over your
past in great detail and figure out
where you are.
It's like you're lost,
you're lost,
and the problem with being last is when
you don't know where to go.
And the problem with not knowing where
to go is there's a million places that
you could go and a million places is too
many places for you to go without dying.
So being lost is not good.
So you need to know where you are.
One of the things that we built online,
my partners and I is this program called
past authoring that helps people lay out
the,
the narrative of their past to identify,
to break their life down into six
stages,
epochs we called them and then to
identify the emotionally significant
moments in each park and to write them
out what happened negatively,
what happened positively,
what the consequences were,
what you derive from it,
perhaps what you could've done
differently,
perhaps what you learned from it,
all of that so that you can narrow in
zero in on determining precisely where
it is that you are right now.
And people are often loathe to do that
because they actually don't want to know
because they'd rather be spread out in a
sort of half blind manner in the fog.
Hoping that the place that they're at is
better than it really is.
And deluding themselves by remaining
vague than to figure out I'm right here
right now with these specific problems,
but it's actually better to to do that
because if you have a set of specific
problems and you've really narrowed them
down and really specified them,
then you can probably start fixing them
and you can start fixing them and Mike
Microwave's bit by bit,
but there's no way you can do that
without knowing where you are.
It's impossible and you can kind of tell
if you don't know where you are.
It's quite straightforward.
If you are haunted by reveries of the
past for events that are older than
approximately 18 months.
If they continue to come up in your mind
over and over and your dreams over and
over,
you haven't extracted the world out from
your past experiences.
That potential is still trapped in the
past and to confront the potential means
to confront the dragon of the past.
And of course that's terrifying.
And 17 seriously be terrifying.
So for example,
maybe you're vague and ill formed an ill
defined because you were abused very
badly when you were a child.
Four years old.
Something like that,
and maybe you were abused by a family
member because that's generally who does
the music and so that just makes it
worse,
and then what that means is that you've
got a implicit.
You had an implicit encountered with
malevolent evil that no,
you've had a direct encounter with
malevolent evil,
but you have an implicit hypothesis of
malevolent evil that's plaguing you.
It's still there.
It's trapped in the memories,
right?
It's trapped in the representational
structure and as an adult you're now
faced with the necessity of articulating
that fully before you have any chance
whatsoever of freeing yourself from it.
And so that's no joke.
Lots of times people have to go into the
past.
That's what the psychoanalysts do and
say,
look,
here's something came along and just
bloody well knocked me over and it isn't
even that I repressed it,
which,
which I think was,
well,
we won't talk about Freud's errors
because freud was a genius,
so we'll just leave him alone.
But,
but sometimes it's not repression.
It's just the terrible things happen to
people at such a young age that there
isn't a bloody chance in hell that they
can figure out why they happened or what
to do with them or what they mean,
and then you can carry that with you and
you carry it with you.
It's like fear your.
Your body encounters the world in stages
and it happens very rapidly.
Well,
it can extend over years,
but the initial stages happened very
rapidly.
So for example,
if you're walking down the road and you
hear a large noise be a loud noise
behind you,
he'll go like this.
That's a Predator defense response by
the way you crouched down and that's to
stop something from jumping on your back
and getting out your neck too easily.
That's like a few,
a few hundred milliseconds.
It's really faster,
even faster than that and it better be
because something like a snake,
but we'll say,
can nail you just right now so you
better be fast,
but it's low resolution.
It's like dangerous snake,
something like that or danger,
predatory cap.
It's that faxed and then you can unravel
that and categorize it,
but that takes time.
You do that with emotion and then you do
it with cognition and you can do that
with longterm thinking,
you know,
because maybe you've encountered someone
specifically malevolent and predatory at
work and it happens to people a lot who
was operating as a,
as a destructive bully and who seems to
have no positive function whatsoever and
he's the only living that out and then
you know,
you don't know what to do about it.
So you're,
you're in prey mode.
I don't mean this kind of mode,
although that would help too,
but I mean you're acting like a prey
animal and then you have this terribly
complex thing to decompose,
which is what the hell is up with this
person?
Why are they making my life miserable?
What is it about B that allows them to
make my life miserable?
That's a nasty little road to walk down
and you're stuck with having to.
You're stuck with having to decompose
it.
Maybe you can't.
Maybe formulating and explicit
philosophy of good and evil to deal with
something malevolent in your environment
actually just happens to be beyond you
and that could easily be.
It's certainly the case for people who
are young and it's the case for plenty
of adults as well.
It's no simple thing to matt to manage.
It's something too that often soldiers
who have posttraumatic stress disorder
have to do because they've encountered
terrible things.
They've either done them or read into
them and they need to update their moral
model of the world or if they end up in
something close closely approximating
hell anyway,
so you need to know where you are.
That's this.
What is.
Where are you?
So you're navigating your navigator.
You're a sailor on an ocean,
man.
That's what.
That's what you are.
You're a mobile creature.
You're going from point a to point b all
the time.
You're not sitting there glued to a rock
like some brainless,
you know,
sea creature.
There's a funny little creature called a
hydra.
Very simple little creature needs
juvenile stage.
It has a brain because it swings around,
but then when it turns into an adult,
it latches itself to Iraq and promptly
digests it's brain because if you're
just sitting on a rock and you're not
moving,
you don't need a brain.
So,
but that's not our issue,
right?
We're zipping around in the world and so
we're navigating agents.
So to navigate,
there's two things you need to know and
the first is where the hell are you?
Exactly.
Precisely right.
Razor sharp.
What's good about you and what's bad
about you buy your own buyer own
reckoning.
You don't have to.
You can ask other people,
but this is a game you play yourself.
It's like as far as I'm concerned,
I'm taking star.
What is it that's okay about being what
needs some work and you got to watch to
not be too self critical when you're
doing that too,
because that can just be another kind of
flaw.